saludos lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es usar algunos resultados de los
vídeos anteriores para hacer algunas
cosas bastante interesantes aquí tengo
un círculo y voy a dibujar adentro un
triángulo equilátero de hecho ya ha
adelantado un poquito por ejemplo ya
tengo esta línea también dibuje esta
otra línea
y esta otra de manera que tengo un
triángulo equilátero y si es equilátero
quiere decir que todos sus lados miden
lo mismo este lado va a medir
este también va a medir a y por supuesto
este también
digamos que sabemos que el radio de este
círculo
el radio que se mide aquí del centro
hacia uno de los lados
este radio yo sé que mide dos unidades
radio igual a 2
que les voy a preguntar es usando los
resultados de los últimos vídeos y un
poco de trigonometría básica
ustedes calculen el área que está dentro
del círculo pero fuera del triángulo es
decir
esta área de acá
esta área que estoy señalando acá
en conjunto o incluyendo esta otra área
de acá
y también esta área de aquí todo lo que
se encuentra por encima del triángulo
pero dentro del círculo
una forma es calcular el área del
círculo que esto es bastante fácil es el
área
el círculo
círculo acento en la y
y por radio al cuadrado
radio al cuadrado y aquí sabemos que
nuestro radio es de 2 por lo que para
este círculo de acá su área spin 4 p 2
al cuadrado es 44 pi
y luego ahí estaba de arrestarle el área
del tren o el área del triángulo área
triángulo
ángulo
bueno está como la voy a calcular si yo
sólo conozco bueno y de hecho no conozco
el valor exacto sólo sé que es un
triángulo equilátero bueno hace algunos
vídeos les mostré la fórmula de heron en
la cual si ustedes conocen los lados de
un triángulo pueden conocer su área
pero aún no conozco cuánto miren estos
lados vamos a aplicar la fórmula de
heron aun cuando no conozca los lados en
la fórmula perón perón
definimos nuestra variable s voy a
escribir mi variable s aparte s es igual
a la suma de los lados del triángulo en
este caso es más
más
entre dos que bueno en este caso es
igual a tres
entre 2
el área ya incluyendo estaba el área
según la fórmula de heron el área del
triángulo va a ser igual a raíz cuadrada
de s en este caso ese estrés a entre 23
a entre 2 por s menos uno de los lados y
aquí los lados son iguales entonces es
ese mensaje que sería 3 entre 2
- ah pero para facilitarme la operación
voy a ponerlo como 2 entre 2 es lo mismo
que esto hemos multiplicado y dividiendo
por 2 y esto va a repetirse tres veces
entonces esto va a ser al cubo todo esto
le saco la raíz cuadrada esto lo puedo
simplificar de manera que me va a quedar
la raíz cuadrada de 3 a entre 23 y entre
3 / 2 - 2 a entre 2 me queda entre 2 al
cubo 3 a entre 2 x a entre 2 al cubo y
todo esto le saco la raíz cuadrada
esto lo desarrollo esto va a ser al cubo
entonces 3 x al cubo va a ser 3 a la
cuarta esto es igual a la raíz cuadrada
3 x a la cuarta 2 al cubo 2 por 2 4 por
2 8 por 2 va a ser 16 13 a la cuarta
entre 16 y de esto quiero obtener la
raíz cuadrada lo sigo simplificando me
va a quedar aquí la raíz cuadrada de aa
la cuarta va a ser a cuadrada aquí sigo
multiplicándolo por la raíz de 3
la raíz cuadrada de 3
16 su raíz cuadrada debe ser 4 4 por 4
el área del triángulo en términos de su
lado si yo encuentro el valor de a y lo
sustituyó aquí entonces voy a encontrar
el área de este triángulo pero bueno
como podemos calcular que conocemos de
triángulos equiláteros bueno es un
triángulo equilátero entonces yo sé que
el ángulo de acá es igual al ángulo de
acá y también es igual al ángulo de acá
y como la suma de estos tres ángulos
interiores debe dar 180 grados pues cada
uno de éstos va a valer 60 grados este
vale 60 este vale 60 y este también 60
grados
luego si podemos usar lo visto en el
último vídeo donde hablamos de la
relación entre un ángulo inscrito y un
ángulo central uno inscrito este vértice
está tocando la circunferencia y tenemos
también un ángulo central pero por
ejemplo para este ángulo inscrito tengo
una cuerda que lo está abarcando voy a
dibujar la cuerda que lo abarca una o
una de las cuerdas que lo abarca aquí
y esta cuerda
si yo llego acá también me va a soportar
o me va a abarcar un ángulo central este
ángulo central se encuentra formado aquí
de este punto hacia este vértice y hacia
este otro vértice
y entonces tengo este ángulo central y
este ángulo inscrito el ángulo central
que abarca este arco será el doble del
ángulo inscrito que comparte con la
misma cual así que este ángulo de aquí
va a ser el doble de este 60 por 2 120
va a medir 120 grados
si yo dice cara este ángulo central es
decir saco una línea que pasa
exactamente por la mitad de este ángulo
y llega a tocar este otro lado
perpendicularmente está esta línea me va
a dividir en este ángulo en dos ángulos
iguales por lo que este ángulo de aquí
me va a quedar de 60 grados y este otro
me va a quedar también de 60 obviamente
este ángulo de aquí también es dividido
a la mitad y me va a quedar aquí 30
grados este chiquito de acá 30 grados y
de estilo otro lado también y como esta
línea está tocando perpendicularmente a
este otro lado aquí me va a formar un
ángulo de 90 grados 90 grados y 90
grados y aquí voy a tener triángulos 30
60 90 esto yo sé que lo puedo hacer
porque este triángulo de acá este
triángulo con los lados azules es un
triángulo isósceles y si yo tengo
cualquier triángulo isósceles
el cual tengo dos lados que son iguales
miden lo mismo este lado mide lo mismo
que este otro lado si yo parto a la
mitad de este ángulo lo vi seco de
manera que llega perpendicularmente a
esta a este otro lado del triángulo este
lado lo voy a dividir exactamente en dos
lados iguales van a medir lo mismo estos
dos y también va a tener como buen
triángulo isósceles estos son ángulos
iguales y aquí voy a formar un ángulo de
90 grados así que la longitud de este
lado del triángulo de acá va a ser igual
a entre 2 la mitad de lo que pedía
originalmente este lado y aquí también a
entre 2 este lado de aquí parte del
centro y llega a un extremo del
triángulo es un radio y si es un radio
también va a valer 2 este lado vale 2 y
este lado del triángulo también vale 2
pero si podemos usar algo de
trigonometría para encontrar una
relación entre a y r si dejamos a en
términos de r vamos a poder encontrar su
valor y así encontrar el área del
triángulo que vamos a restar a su vez al
área del círculo y encontrar las áreas
que nos interesa a ver entonces tenemos
aquí un ángulo de 60 grados el lado
opuesto a este ángulo es a entre 2 vamos
a notarlo en este caso lo opuesto
del ángulo de 60 grados es igual a entre
2 y como tenemos un triángulo rectángulo
pues entonces podemos aplicar algo de
trigonometría también sé de este dato
que la hipotenusa está de acá que es la
opuesta al ángulo recto vale 2
hipotenusa hipotenusa
es igual a 2
tiene función trigonométricas en los
relaciona el lado opuesto con la
hipotenusa bueno aquí siempre es bueno
recordar nuestro sol
tenemos el opuesto la hipotenusa pues va
a ser el seno entonces el seno lo voy a
escribir por acá el seno de el ángulo
que me interesa de 60 grados
es igual al opuesto el opuesto es entre
entre 2
entre la hipotenusa que vale 2
qué es lo mismo que esto es igual a
entre 4
cuál es el seno de 60 grados si no lo
saben los invito a que vean los primeros
vídeos de la serie de trigonometría del
canal de khan academy
recordando nuestros triángulos 30 60 90
voy a dibujarlo también por acá para que
lo recordemos bien los triángulos que
son más o menos así
y que tienen un ángulo pues un ángulo
recto de 90 grados
tienen un ángulo de 30 grados y otro
ángulo de 60 grados bueno para este tipo
de triángulos como los definimos en el
vídeo de trigonometría aquí la
hipotenusa mide 11 esto va a medir este
lado un medio
y aquí va a medir raíz de 3 entre 2
así que el seno que es el opuesto al
ángulo de 60 grados entre la hipotenusa
el seno de este seno de 60 grados
es igual al lado opuesto raíz de 3 entre
2 esto es con base al círculo unitario
entre la hipotenusa que vale 1 por lo
tanto es igual al raíz de 3
entre 2
así que este seno de 60 grados vale raíz
cuadrada de 3 entre 2
ahora yo puedo encontrar el valor de a
si sé qué raíz cuadrada de 3 entre 2
es igual a entre 4
multiplicó todo por 44 por raíz cuadrada
de 3 entre 2
24 entre 2 me va a quedar a 2 este 4 se
va si lo multiplicó aquí 14 estos dos se
van de manera que me va a quedar a igual
a 2 por raíz de 3
y llamamos en la recta final
sustituyamos este valor de a en la
fórmula de heron para encontrar el área
del triángulo que damos que ese es el
área voy a hacer un poquito de espacio
porque ya no tengo vamos a volverlo acá
está el área del triángulo
le pongo aquí el triángulo para ver
enviar
es igual a cuadrada qué es esto dos por
raíz de 3
al cuadrado por raíz de 3
entre 4 simplificamos esto al elevarlo
al cuadrado me queda aquí 4 raíces
vuelve 3 esto va a ser igual a 4 por 3
por raíz de 3
entre 4 estos 24 se van me queda que eso
es igual a 3 por raíz de tres este es el
área del triángulo
todo este triángulo su área
es igual a 3 por raíz de 3
todo este triángulo de h muy bien
y regresando a nuestro problema en donde
queremos encontrar el área dentro del
círculo pero fuera del triángulo pues ya
quedamos que el área de circular a 4 pin
lo regresó a que para que vean el área
del círculo es 4 pi entonces hacemos
esta resta 4 y el área del círculo menos
3 por raíz cuadrada de 3 y hemos
terminado esta es el área que buscamos
aquí